dogs
they can smell cancer with their noses
their tongues are more powerful than a
rocket
and they could be driving us around
someday soon
i always say dog is my co-pilot i mean
this is literally he's my cop he's my
pilot
[Music]
plus
the polar bear
it's not really white
it can stop a pregnancy in its tracks
and it may just offer a cure
for human obesity
and polar bears are literally the
ultimate of the bears
and
find out how the clubs of the four inch
long mantis shrimp can ko floyd money
mayweather
and protect us against bombs on the
battlefield
it's survived
without producing any shrapnel
[Music]
this is where savage meets science
wild becomes
wow
is
everything you didn't know about animals
[Music]
they fought gladiators in rome
and can regenerate their own bones
they might help make humans invisible at
night
and they may even provide a cure for
diabetes
[Music]
they came from brown bears but now
they're a green apart
[Music]
they're polar bears
the largest four-legged carnivore in the
world
here in the arctic temperatures can drop
to a brutal minus 60 degrees fahrenheit
in these conditions exposed human skin
can freeze in under five minutes
but what we call inhospitable
the polar bear calls home
polar bears are literally the ultimate
of the bears they're these giant white
bears roaming around in an environment
that looks more like the surface of the
moon to think that an animal can make a
living out there is pretty impressive
they even have a third eyelid which acts
like sunglasses to prevent snow
blindness
in fact every part of this master
adapter is a testament to how perfectly
built they are for their environment
[Music]
beginning with this
a liver so specialized adding it to your
diet could kill you
and that's after your skin peels off
a polar bear's liver contains 10 to 20
times more vitamin a than almost any
other mammal on earth
it's an adaptation for surviving almost
exclusively on seal fat
which just happens to be super high in
vitamin a goes right into their body as
storage and it's that highly rich food
that highly nutritious food that has
allowed polar bears to become the
largest of all the bears
and also the bear with the largest
amount of vitamin a in its liver
a polar bear's liver contains over 30
times the recommended daily allowance in
humans
it would take 43 boxes of fortified
cereal flakes to equal the vitamin a in
just one gram of polar bear liver
if a human tried to harness some of that
power the results wouldn't be pretty
[Music]
it starts with a headache your vision
blurs
next thing you know
your skin starts to peel and death comes
calling
diagnosis
polar bear poisoning
so hold the onions this liver is off the
menu
of all eight bear species alive today
the polar bear is the youngest
but a lot has happened in the 500 000
years since this
became this
[Music]
a lot of their traits are adaptations to
living in arctic conditions
they have very small ears compared to
other bears and that's thought to keep
in warmth
but you need more than small ears in a
land cold enough to turn motor oil into
ice cubes
to earn the title of master adapter
you need to be so good at keeping warm
you're invisible to infrared
first
if you look beneath the polar bear's fur
you'll see that this white warrior is
actually black
that dark color soaks up the sun's rays
for warmth
just like a car's leather seats
on a sunny day
but it takes more than sunshine to keep
warm in the arctic
so under that black skin
the polar bear has a four inch thick
layer of blubber to trap in their body
heat
that fat keeps them so well insulated
that when you look at a polar bear on an
infrared camera
you see nothing at all
[Music]
okay
almost nothing
if you fly over it with an infrared
camera most of the body doesn't glow
very strongly at all so they're
relatively uh
hidden
from the standpoint of how much heat
they radiate
some research suggests modeling the
insulating properties of polar bears
to create high-tech camouflage
which future soldiers could use to avoid
infrared detection on the battlefield
to be the master adapter you have to be
able to hunt your prey without being
seen
they figured out it's better to be white
if you're out here in a white
environment to sneak up on seals
even more ingenious they figured out how
to look white without actually being
white
look closely and you'll see
polar bear hairs are transparent
and hollow
when sunlight penetrates the clear
hollow hair
it bounces off the inner core then gets
scattered back out into the environment
so why the white appearance
the normal ambient light that comes from
the sun we call white light
sometimes in really bright light the
polar bears almost look like they're
glowing because of the way that the
light is scattered they look almost
too white to be natural
but if you're a seal all you'll see is
another white mound on a landscape of
white mounds until you see nothing at
all
[Music]
a polar bear's bite is estimated to be
more powerful than a great white shark
and has the biggest pause of any bear a
full 12 to 18 inches across
at least an inch larger than most dinner
plates
that is huge and they actually been
known to kill an animal with just one
single blow that's how strong these guys
are
but the polar bear isn't just a fighter
also perfectly adapted for love
with a nose that can sniff out a mate
from over 200 000 feet away
[Music]
looking for love can be hard when you're
as spread out as polar bears
when i was radio tracking polar bears in
northern alaska the largest activity
area that i measured was 230 000 square
miles or nearly the size of the state of
texas
a long way to go for love
but distance makes the heart grow fonder
and smellier a brand new study released
in early 2015
shows that female polar bears use
special scent glands in their paws
to leave love notes in the snow
[Music]
and the male gets the message
[Music]
we've seen situations where we're
following a bear from a helicopter and
it was kind of meandering around like
this and all of a sudden boom it took
off in a straight line for 40 miles
when we caught up with it it was right
on the tail
of a female that was in breeding
condition
that would be like smelling your dates
perfume in toledo ohio when you're
standing in ann arbor michigan
and once two polar bears hook up the
female can employ its next incredible
adaptation
something humans only wish they could do
but first
even though the polar bear stands out as
a notorious carnivore
it shares the same legal classification
as one of these other less lethal
animals is it
a the dolphin
b
the elephant
or c
the koala
a polar bear can eat the equivalent of
an entire adult human
in just one sitting
once a polar bear digs into its meal it
can gorge on 150 pounds of meat at a
time that's up to 20 percent of its own
body weight
[Music]
if a 170 pound man ate 20 percent of his
own weight that would be like scarfing
down a 34 pound steak
before the break we asked which of these
animals has the same legal
classification as a polar bear
is it
a the dolphin
b the element
or c the koala
the answer
the polar bear is in the same boat with
the dolphin
[Music]
just like dolphins
whales
and even
seals the polar bear is considered a
marine mammal
all of their nutrition comes from that
marine
food chain and so they've been
classified as marine mammals
but we've given the polar bear another
title
that of master adapter
the show how they've earned that moniker
we're eliminating some of the polar
bears most ingenious traits for
surviving at the top of the world
including the female's ability to
conserve the energy needed to survive
by stopping a pregnancy in its tracks
first
the egg is fertilized
and the race is on for the female to put
on as much weight as possible
over 400 pounds in just a few months but
here's the amazing part
if she doesn't gain enough weight
her body can stop the pregnancy
so she doesn't waste resources carrying
cubs she can't care for
take a closer look at how it works
the egg is fertilized but then
development stops at a matter of just a
few dozen or a few hundred cells a stage
of development that we call the blast
assist that blastocyst will stay in the
fallopian tube
and if the polar bear decides she's not
fat enough
she will actually reabsorb the
blastocyst into her system
how is that possible and can humans do
that like
gee it would be really nice if i had a
job right now i can't really afford a
baby maybe maybe maybe next time kid
but if the polar bear does commit to the
pregnancy things get really
extreme and as it turns out
the way she gives birth
might help give life to humans
[Music]
when a polar bear goes into her den to
give birth
she won't eat
expel waste
or move for the next seven months
[Music]
if humans spent as many months lying
around
we'd lose a third of our bone mass
and going that long without a bathroom
break
would kill our kidneys
so it's possible that studying how polar
bears survive these extreme conditions
could help us better understand things
like kidney disease in humans
but that's just a theory
scientists are already studying the
polar bear to provide cures for the
approximately 190 million people
worldwide suffering from obesity and
diabetes
here's how
when females leave the den they will
have lost half their body weight
but in just a few months she'll pack it
all back on and then some
that sort of a change in body weight
would be lethal to humans
but amazingly polar bears are still able
to maintain appropriate insulin and
blood sugar balances
how
researchers at uc berkeley have
identified several mutated polar bear
genes
that seem connected to the way they
survive their high fat diets
studying these genes is the first step
to creating genetic tools
that could one day allow us to cope with
our own high fat diets
obesity high cholesterol
type 2 diabetes
even heart disease
in a real way the fat of the world's
biggest four-legged predator could help
cure some of the biggest killers of
humans
who needs weight watchers
[Music]
wanna save the
whales get a dog
the poop sniffing dog was a hero to
conservationists
but that's not all
their noses can take you to court
or protect you from seizures
they might be driving you around someday
soon
[Music]
and they may just help humans live past
100
man's best friend
more like humanity's greatest gift
dogs are next
[Music]
this hero can smell cancer cells in your
body
and hear secret messages recorded by
rock stars
they can help you survive a heart attack
and may even be critical to saving some
of our most endangered species from
extinction
they're small they're big and they've
been sharing our homes for up to 30 000
years
they're dogs and they might just be one
of the most capable animals on the
planet
you know i think dogs are the best deal
mankind ever made we give them the time
we can share and the love we can spare
and they give us their absolute all
but even though they're the world's
first domestic pet there's still a lot
these furry sidekicks can do that we're
just beginning to realize
to prove it
we're counting down seven of the most
surprising things you might not have
known the dog could do
starting with this
dogs can drive
[Applause]
[Music]
it's not a joke
[Music]
researchers in new zealand have taught
dogs to burn rubber using special
modified cars
it was a campaign to basically raise
awareness at how smart dogs can be
i always say dog is my co-pilot
this is literally my cop he's my pilot
these driving dogs can start the engine
put it in gear
and even turn on a dime
[Music]
between driver's ed and getting a
learner's permit it takes most human
teenagers at least six months before
they can drive on their own
these dogs learned it all in just two
months
so who knows maybe the streets of the
future will be filled with furry
chauffeurs
[Music]
while driving dogs might make the world
more dangerous for cats
for the most part canines do a pretty
good job of making things safer for
everyone
which is why the second most surprising
thing you might not have known dogs
could do is this
they can take you to court
well sort of
meet the bloodhound a dog with a nose so
powerful
it's admissible as evidence in 45 states
a bloodhound named nick carter once
helped capture and convict over 600
criminals they see the world in a
completely different way than us largely
because
they see through their smell so their
smell is really how they take everything
in
to give you an idea i think everybody
can think of an nfl stadium in a city
the size of that
if you were to fill that stadium up with
all yellow tennis balls
and one blue tennis ball then if each
tennis ball represented a molecule
ascent
some of these dogs can detect that one
blue tennis ball in a whole stadium
filled full yellow tennis balls
that's how incredible their scent is
bloodhounds have been known to pick up a
scent trail up to 300 hours old
for fugitives that means even if you
have a 12 and a half day head start the
bloodhound can still hunt you down
also dogs can drive now so good luck
running
dogs are one of the most diverse species
in the world in fact there's more
differences between the skulls of great
danes and pugs than there are between
weasels and walruses
that's why number three on our list is
that dogs can evolve with incredible
speed
[Music]
whether big or small all dogs came from
the same place
the gray wolf
but how do we go from these guys
to this
150 years ago we didn't have nearly the
variety we do today
but when queen victoria started showing
off a rare chinese pekingese
the public went wild customizing canines
through breeding
now with over 400 recognized breeds and
new ones being created all the time
dogs are the most buried animal on the
planet
from one of the tallest
a great dane named zeus who on his hind
legs stood seven feet four inches
to one of the smallest
millie a one pound chihuahua
there's skye the wire fox terrier who
won best in show
and then there's peanuts
proud winner of the world's ugliest dog
contest
as an owner of two pugs obviously i like
homely dogs i think they're cute
today there are roughly 525 million pet
dogs across the whole planet
that's over one and a half times the
population of the entire united states
and still not one representative in
congress
as legend has it the explorer ponce de
leon came to florida in 1513 searching
for the proverbial fountain of youth
but maybe he should have been looking a
little closer to home
because when it comes to aging
dogs may just hold the secret to keeping
us young at heart
and body
[Music]
they may quite literally be the fountain
of youth
according to multiple studies dogs
already have a huge impact on human
health
just owning a dog can lower your
cholesterol by at least two percent
reducing your chance for a heart attack
by four percent
and should the worst happen dogs can
help with that too one of the profound
things we've found is that survivors of
heart attacks within that first year
after having a heart attack those that
have a dog have a better outlook of
surviving
but it doesn't stop there
dogs can be trained to detect seizures
before they happen and can even smell
cancer in humans with up to 95 accuracy
they can alert you sometimes with a much
greater accuracy than our normal medical
tests
that that person may or may not have
cancer so it's pretty amazing
as if that isn't enough
brand new research into canine aging
might just hold the key to stopping the
clock on aging in humans
we know that there's this big difference
in body size across the dogs but that
difference also then translates into a
difference in how long the animal lives
so an irish wolfhound is only going to
live half as long as that chihuahua
on average every four additional pounds
on a dog translates to a loss of
approximately one month of life
expectancy
larger dogs actually age faster
then we're still trying to figure out
why and does that relate in some way to
human aging you know so that's one of
the questions that we're interested in
to find those answers in 2014 adam boyco
and other researchers teamed up with the
national institute of aging to form the
first ever canine longevity consortium
[Music]
its goal is to study dogs of all
different sizes to find how things like
genetic and environmental factors or
even a few extra pounds
might influence aging
and since dogs and humans share so much
of the same environment they hope this
research will have a significant impact
on how we treat geriatric illness in
humans
because of age-related research studies
with similar goals
some scientists believe the first person
to live to be 150
has already been born
there doesn't seem to be much the dog
can't do
they can even hear secret messages
recorded by rock stars can you guess
which musical group recorded a secret
sound for their dog in one of their most
famous songs
was it a rem
b
the beatles
or c
radiohead
plus find out how a dog's tongue is more
powerful than a space shuttle
dogs they can hear four times farther
away than humans
and they can tune in on pitches two
times higher than us
[Applause]
that's rock star hearing and one band
understood this better than others
before the break we asked you which
musical group recorded a secret sound
for their dog in one of their most
famous songs
was it a rem
b the beatles or c radiohead
the answer
it was the fab for themselves the
beatles
in the song a day in the life paul
mccartney recorded an ultrasonic whistle
that was only audible to his sheepdog
[Music]
all new dogs have some pretty amazing
abilities but even he might be amazed by
our list of the seven most surprising
things dogs can do
for number five
we're going underground
because hard as it might be to believe
dogs can ride the subway
[Music]
moscow russia
a city of roughly 35 000 stray dogs
and incredibly a handful of them have
figured out how to get around using the
city's elaborate subway system
with 202 miles of track and 194
different stations
the moscow subway is one of the biggest
and busiest in europe
this is not a random occurrence it
appears that these dogs know where
they're going just like humans do they
get on at a certain stop they get off at
a certain stop maybe they're going to go
visit their friend the schnauzer
vladimir who knows i don't know
but even above ground dogs seem to have
an almost super ability to find their
way around
how do they do it
scientists believe they may be able to
navigate the world by sensing the
earth's magnetic field
and the way experts discovered how dogs
know where to go
was by watching how they go
[Music]
here's something most dog owners can
relate to
you'll go outside and it's cold and
you're thinking hurry up would you hurry
up
they're sniffing they're moving they're
circling and finally they plant this
fecal flag
i call the careful placing dengshui
that's how careful it is
in a two-year study researchers observed
70 dogs of different breeds going to the
bathroom seven thousand times
and what they found was that dogs prefer
to align themselves along the earth's
north south axis when doing the deed
it's like they have a compass
and their butts
so while we can't be sure it's possible
dogs may be using this super sixth sense
to help navigate things like the moscow
underground
[Music]
or at least your neighbor's begonias
[Music]
contrary to what you may have heard
dogs tongues are not cleaner than your
own mouth
it's actually a hotbed of bacteria
[Music]
but we let them give us facials anyway
i mean i've been on network tv and told
four million people
to not let your pet lick you in the
mouth because of the potential threat of
zoonotic diseases
and i do exactly the opposite of what i
told these people to do you know i let
the dog jump up my left oh give daddy
sugars daddy loves you
of course the dog uses its tongue for
more than just cleaning our pores
it really comes out to play when a dog
wants to grab a drink
and the incredible way that they do that
is our surprising skill number six
a dog's tongue can defy the forces of
gravity
so when you watch a dog drinking
you would think okay they just kind of
like scoop it up in their tongue but
actually their tongue's more like a
ladle
look closely and you'll see that the
tongue bends back
making a reverse cuff that scoops up
water
with eight times the force of gravity
to put that in perspective when an
astronaut launches into orbit
it's at 1.7 times the force of gravity
or 1.7 g's so a dog is lapping up water
with almost five times the g's
astronauts feel at takeoff
and that's not the dog's only connection
to outer space
the first living creature to ever orbit
the earth was a dog named lyka
in your face neil armstrong
[Music]
wouldn't it be great if we could tell
what our dogs were thinking
[Music]
researchers at north carolina state
recently unveiled a prototype harness
packed with sensors that might in a way
achieve that goal
[Music]
this harness allows the owner to monitor
their dog's mood
stress level and even its posture all
from a wireless device
so the dream of being able to read your
dog's mind might not be such a fantasy
after all
hint
they want bacon
or maybe they want to save the world
for our seventh and final thing dogs can
do
we're looking at how their noses might
actually save other animals from
extinction
from killer whales to the elusive gibbon
everybody poops
and for conservationists that stuff is
as valuable as gold
collecting dna from animal scat is one
of the key ways modern researchers track
what factors might be leading to a
species decline
and what steps can be taken to stop it
so getting to the poop is important
problem is finding feces isn't easy
unless you're a dog
dogs be trained to find the excrement of
up to 18 different endangered species
and it's already making a huge
difference
in 25 years of trying to collect orca
scat pacific northwest scientists could
count on one hand how many samples they
found
just one dog named tucker found 150 in
six months
and he can smell the scat
in the ocean
from over 5000 feet away
[Music]
[Applause]
that's almost like standing at the top
of the grand canyon and smelling poop at
the bottom
[Music]
with over 16 000 species currently
listed as endangered
in a very real way the dog's nose might
help save the planet
and so the poop sniffing dog
you know is a hero to conservationists
it's a dirty job but someone's gotta do
it
now
who needs a ride
[Music]
the mantis shrimp
it has a punch as strong as a bullet
eyes that can see cancer
[Music]
the speed to vaporize water
and the strength to help build the next
generation of army tanks
it might just be pound for pound the
toughest animal in the world
[Music]
it lives in the ocean
but may shape the airplanes of the
future
it's just a few inches long but it might
save the lives of athletes on the
gridiron
and soldiers on the battlefield
someday this animal may even help you to
literally see cancer with your phone
all that and it punches with the force
of a bullet
shot from a gun
meet the mantis shrimp pound for pound
one of the strongest animals in the
world
from gorillas
to grizzly bears
there are a lot of obvious choices for
world's strongest
[Music]
making a strong showing for the top spot
is the small and unassuming mantis
shrimp usually being called a shrimp is
an insult but if you call somebody a
manta strip you might as well just call
them a swift and effective death machine
i mean they're only four inches long and
we literally have to keep them in their
own plastic tanks so the fear is that
one of the glass tanks will be shattered
but how can something so small compete
for a title as big as world's strongest
it takes a number of powerful elements
beginning with
a punch as powerful as a 22 caliber
bullet
if there's any doubt how strong that is
just talk to the people who study mantis
shrimps up close so if you leave through
the laboratory notebooks you'll suddenly
see a bunch of dark brown smudges which
are the blood of the volunteers a lot of
blood was spilled
no wonder a mantis shrimp's nickname is
the thumb splitter
but where does all that power come from
the clubs of a mantis shrimp are
essentially spring-loaded
by contracting its muscles it stores a
massive amount of energy in this curved
saddle-shaped structure
then the mantis shrimp latches it all
into place
think of it like a crossbow
with the string pulled back and the bolt
locked in and ready to fire when the
latch is released the saddle pops
and the club accelerates at over 50
miles per hour and it creates a peak
force of over 330 pounds
that's up to 2500 times its own weight
if a 135 pound man could punch 2500
times his own weight he could hit with
10 times the pressure it takes to break
steel
but the mantis shrimp also has a secret
weapon loaded in that punch one that
makes it even more powerful it is a
shock wave nearly as hot as the sun
the mantis shrimp swings its devastating
ko and less than 800 microseconds
the fastest predatory strike in the
ocean
it's so fast that theoretically in the
time it takes you to blink once
the mantis shrimp can punch 500 times
so you don't even see it coming
it's just walking down the street dead
that lightning fast punch
boils the surrounding water
creating a tiny vapor bubble
when the bubble collapses it creates a
powerful shock wave that's over 8 000
degrees fahrenheit
almost as hot as the surface of the sun
it even generates a flash of light
it's a destructive force called
cavitation so we've kind of got this one
two punch
the poor prey that have to suffer their
wrath feel the impact from their clubs
and then the cavitation bubbles also
implode on their prey
blowing up clams is impressive but the
mantis shrimp is powerful enough to take
on much greater foes
with the most advanced visual system in
the animal kingdom
they can help humans see cancer
consider this
the human eye has just two kinds of
photoreceptor cells
one for light and dark and one for color
but the mantis shrimps eye has up to 16
different kinds of photoreceptor cells
no other eye has that number of photo
pigments that gives them the broadest
visual spectrum capability of any animal
we know of
the mantis shrimp is being studied to
help humans see things like cancer cells
before they
when metastasize cells are put under
polarized light they scatter the light
differently than normal body cells
problem is humans can't see polarized
light with the naked eye but the mantis
shrimp can
so using the mantis shrimp's eye as a
model
researchers are developing a camera
small enough to fit in most phones
and capable of detecting these cancer
cells before they have a chance to
spread
it's just one more way the mantis strip
fights for the title of world's
strongest
[Music]
but what if you could harness the mantis
shrimp's incredible power if your arms
were as fast as his how far do you think
you could throw a baseball
would it be
a from new york to california
b
new york to tokyo
or c the big apple into outer space
plus
find out how this four inch marbles
exoskeleton could finally make humans
bulletproof
[Music]
the mantis shrimp
a four inch long crustacean that just
happens to have the most powerful punch
known to man
before the break
we asked if you could harness the mantis
shrimp speed in your own arms how far do
you think you could throw a baseball
would it be
a
from new york to california
b
new york to tokyo
or c the big apple into outer space
heads up the answer is c
in fact
by using just 10 of a mantis shrimp's
acceleration
you could blast a baseball into orbit
600 times faster
than a nasa rocket
a punch like a bullet
explosion like the sun
the mantis shrimp is pound for pound
one of the strongest animals in the
world
earlier we told you that the mantis
strip could punch with a force of up to
2500 times the weight of its own body
but how does that stack up against
the best boxer on earth
at five foot eight inches 151 pounds
with a record of over 45 wins
[Music]
floyd money mayweather jr is considered
pound for pound the best fighter in the
world
in the human world that is
as good as mayweather is
if he could punch 2500 times his own
weight
that right hook would hit with the force
of
377 000 pounds
that's like getting punched with enough
force to get a 767 off the ground
[Music]
since as far as we know mayweather can't
do that
mantis shrimp wins
but to punch that hard without blowing
up its own arms
the mantis shrimp has the power to stop
its clubs from breaking at a molecular
level
its clubs are exactly as strong as they
need to be
the clubs of the smashing mantis shrimp
aren't actually fists
they're really more of an elbow
and the secret to their durability
is a special shock-absorbent core
one that has a molecular structure
unlike any other animal we know
look closer
[Music]
you'll see a unique arrangement of
spiraling fibers called a booligan
structure
these spirals keep microscopic cracks
from becoming major splits so let's say
you took a a plate and you drop the
plate which is a ceramic material on the
ground
any cracks
formed in the plate would just propagate
right through and it would shatter
in this case a crack would have to
propagate through this entire spiral of
fibers and so it absorbs a lot of energy
that crack will run out of energy before
it can go through this entire spiral
this allows the mantis trim to deliver
punch after shell shocking punch
without the clubs breaking
in fact these tiny clubs may just be
pound for pound
as strong as a tank
at the very least they could make tanks
stronger researchers like david casales
are mimicking the molecular structure of
the mantis shrimps clubs to build
high-tech materials that are peaking the
interest of the u.s military
it's pretty amazing i mean we just got a
7.5 million dollar grant from the
department of defense to form a team
where we are looking for common designs
where we can actually make next
generation lightning materials based on
the designs of the manta shrimp
we built a half a pound of high
explosives and put it right here where
you see this this circle and we
detonated it
and
as you can see there's lots of damage
inside here
but the whole panel still holds together
and it's only five millimeters thick so
it's very lightweight five times less
dense than steel and yet it's survived
an ied without producing any shrapnel
but it's not just for the military we're
actually taking it to the next level
where we can actually manufacture
lightweight composite materials for a
number of applications
better football helmets
stronger automobiles
even lighter airplanes
the entire world may become a lot
stronger
all based on a four-inch sea creatures
clubs
so remember this name
the mantis shrimp it might just one day
save your life
[Music]
you